un conteneur c'est le lieu insolite que
le groupement d'employeurs clé jobs a
installé depuis fin août dans le
quartier du val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie
objectif permettre aux jeunes de trouver
un emploi ou une formation
pourquoi une boîte métallique parce que
c'est peut-être le format le plus ouvert
tout cas c'est ce que nous avons trouvé
c'est à dire pour être un plus hors les
murs pour être plus ouverts à tous les
publics pour justement attirer même
parfois par curiosité mais de toute
façon tous ceux qui nous approchent sont
concernés d'une manière ou d'une autre
par l'emploi ou la formation appelée
kiosque pour l'emploi est installée
jusqu'à fin 2000 21 municipalités
entreprises espèrent repéré mille jeunes
et réaliser 100 à 150 embauches directes
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'ici on
est au coeur du quartier du val fourré
l'endroit où il ya le plus de chômage à
mantes la jolie et notamment chez des
jeunes et donc le fait d'être en hyper
proximité et surtout de proposer des
offres d'emploi immédiatement
disponibles suite à un procès ce qui est
en train d'être aude et ça permet de
répondre tout de suite aux demandes
d'emploi pour le préfet délégué à
l'égalité des chances ce concept
s'inscrit dans le plan de relance mis en
place par le gouvernement dont un tiers
des actions concernent l'accès à
l'emploi des jeunes il faut des
initiatives comme ça partout dans sur
territoire pour montrer aux jeunes des
quartiers que l'accès à l'emploi est
possible que l'accès l'emploi est pas
réservé aux autres que c'est pas
toujours pour les autres que la
république tient ses promesses mais que
c'est pour tout le monde et notamment et
surtout pour les pour eux qui en ont
plus particulièrement besoin
une douzaine de concepts similaires sont
ou seront installés dans la région
parisienne dans les yvelines un autre
conteneur sera bientôt disponible dans
la gare de versailles chantiers